what is love baby don't hurt me no I
felt that was a pretty big title for
this episode there's just one called
what is life and it's like but you got a
really big laugh out of what the hell
was that why the gun show yeah those mic
tickets to the gun show career I didn't
get it
neither did I then is it just random
it's just no what I don't think so okay
she is she's over here and was shown
what you were doing you know what you
were doing the gun show for his arm to
be fixed okay he's gonna get better he's
going to be improved rights
what do bodybuilder type people do they
go and build muscles sometimes guys will
say a gun show this is these are their
guns are you high
not yet somebody in the comments please
tell them I'm not crazy okay this is why
you're a go away
yes come back you kids and come back you
make a little bit more sense but only a
little turn around
oh no robbery okay I have no idea who
that lady was I don't know this is as
random as the episode we just saw
honestly no I said that is the one thing
comes to mind with this one this is like
one of the really quick fast especially
random ones I guess not random there is
a story and it's that what was it Jake
really pranks been with a big bag of
butter yes and Finn wants revenge he
wants to get prank at him so he creates
this was it's a microwave with a can on
it
call neptr never-ending-pie-throwing
and another great design simply because
he has a can uh that has eyes and the N
efface it but then lightning strikes it
comes to life but the face is on the
side so there's just this pointless cat
with a face under the table and he he
never bothers to take it up he just um
it's a horrible place for the face to be
too honest I'm not on the side of the
microwave it's like who would put the
face especially since that goes in the
opposite like he would be imagine
walking sideways your entire life and
never being able to look the way you're
walking yeah it's kind of like those
crabs that walk this way you know yeah
but at least its eyes can see a doctor
can't yes so but again that's the great
tragedy of neptr and the the science of
whitening logic they have put spaces on
the side so apparently they though I
forget what they actually had to go
through I know they had been to the Ice
King to get something with his lightning
I forgot what it actually was just just
lightning bolt Jesse was the lightning
that struck him into life and he wasn't
fully made so now what's that mean fully
melee he couldn't get pies or something
well this lamp was cold and his arm
wasn't working properly okay weren't
working properly okay she's back there
again going oh no
it's random but not that random I don't
know about that the ICP I'll tell you
what if we ever meet up with the creator
you'll be able to ask him and so okay
okay so they go the Ice King and is that
is that the first time we seen cooter it
we've seen them before it's as is from
my memory it's the first thing he's
named okay if you always seek out
because I think I think we saw him
before and the one of us so worried
actually the first thing you see the eye
scan yeah yes um so let's first I mean
here is named Gunther yeah so I keep
saying cooter it's either isn't it
actually funny story this is something I
did learn when Tom Kenny was reading the
script if it had the moon Lots he would
say it that way if it didn't he would
say it that way that's how there's
two versions of the name wait so does
does the character King actually go back
and forth l that's funny yeah so they
forget okay
so and I'm sure matches the show fine
like you know just call Gunther today
and gun through the next day so okay so
he gets hit with the lightning and that
really funny were Finn tries to block
you but that the lightning goes over him
neptr right yes okay and but the Ice
King now has like a part of him in neptr
he's like his son now and neptr is torn
and he decides to go with Finn but then
the Ice King like has a single tear go
down and the imagines what it'd be like
to be with his microwave with can on top
son and it's kind of a sad day for me it
shows that there's more to the Ice King
than just him being some crazy guy who
wants to hunt down princesses he's
because notice when he first enters he's
like is that you and he's like that's
what it would be like really sad as
episode like that's what it would be
like if I had a real girlfriend I had a
life and he's got that bed with like the
leopard skin she's like even wings like
reading a book or doing something on
there he's are like laying a stomach
like twiddling his feet and stuff he's
quite a sad character like especially in
this one like yeah he's talking to neptr
saying you can catch princesses and
stuff like that but in the end neptr in
his dream or you know dream world or
whatever he goes nectars like hey you
want to go catch princesses and okay ice
creams like no let's just stay here a
little bit longer it really says that I
guess on the one hand it's like I I
guess I've a the episodes so far to have
the title what is life I guess this is
deserving but it's like that's such a
heavy title you know I'd almost like it
have like nothing to do with life cuz
you know like that's the joke but I did
now I'm really just read it even do
though analyzing too much uh so it's
it's a good episode ooh
more about the ice gang I think he's
always been kind of a pathetic character
I mean that's like even from the first
time he shows up it's like oh this guy's
just kind of a loser like yes didn't
take you knows that he has to take
people to love him and stuff um but yeah
so I mean he's a lot of fun I like this
neptr thing this again just a great
design with the face on the side and
again at that I think it's really funny
um okay so here's a question for you
well first of I forgot to say in the
last one the woman who did the witch uh
that was a really good that was good
voice act that though it's just really
funny I just we have to say that but
segue into something else okay the guy
who does Jake's voice the earth yeah the
dog yeah what's his name again
John George on demand Joe to munjin I
have no idea how to say anything okay
and ER yeah so what that's what's gonna
ask because a lot of people they talk
about this guy like you know that this
guy is such a great voice actor isn't he
wonderful isn't he fantastic and I hear
the guy and I gotta brown with him at
all like I think he's good at what he
does um but hey every time I hear his
voice it's always his voice he never
really tries to disguise it or anything
and which is not bad you know but be uh
what am i hearing it's sort of a basic
sort of straightforward comedic
performance like I don't see as
fantastic I don't see as bad but I'm
wearing like again I know he's got a big
fan page so that's like I don't dislike
him at all you know I be he's fine what
he does but what is especially being a
fan of show what is the attraction to
that voice actor because people just go
nuts for him honestly I don't know I
know him from Futurama this and then he
did a documentary oh my god what's it
called a docudrama about carl panzram
the director is john Borowski he does
the narration for it and it's really
cool because it's not you're right
anytime I've heard him it's the bender
voice for his normal voice but when he
does the voice for the narration it's
kind of this creepy very just like like
it's a very very very different than
I'm used to other than that I haven't
heard anything that's gonna say maybe
it's just not maybe it's just not being
aware of like the other stuff he's dead
maybe for his voice like a million times
that we never knew that's true that
could actually be very possible I I know
he did the Joker once in one of those
straight-to-dvd really yeah it wasn't
that bad oh you know I I mean he he The
Joker strangely enough was not doing it
much mmm you know but you know it it was
decent but at the same time I was in
like yeah it's bender yeah and ER but
it's it it wasn't that bad um but yeah I
was always sort of wondering what the
fascination so the people that love that
voice actor I get we don't dislike him
or anything but you talk about we like
about I'm actually just really curious
what he's been in so we can maybe check
it out yeah maybe we gonna see more
stuff with him cuz like lice he's fine
I mean there's nothing wrong but I just
seen people just like isn't a genius
isn't he unbelievable I'm like yeah you
know it's just I'm just curious what the
fascination is so to talk about your
fascination woman crush man crush
whatever you got down below so I get off
on that don't act like you don't